- [Announcer] This UCSD TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Ajit] Good afternoon. My name is Ajit
Varki. I'm the co-director of the Center
for Academic Research and Training in
Anthropogeny, or CARTA, along with Rusty
Gage, my co-director, and Margaret
Schoeninger couldn't be here today. I'd
like to welcome you to this very special
event. As you probably know, some of you
know, CARTA is dedicated to the search for
explaining our origins. Who are we? How
did we get here and where are we going?
And some terms. So, much of our activity
has to do with public symposia,
interactions with the public and also
private discussions involving a
trans-disciplined group of scientists from
all across the world, spanning many
disciplines. But the other aspect of our
work that you may not be as aware of is
that we focus a lot on the future
generation. We have a group of specialty
students in this Specialization Track for
Anthropogeny. And the other thing we have,
which is very special, is a group of very
well-known advisers from all across the
world. So, once in a while, we tap on one
of these advisers to come and visit us. In
this case, we are bringing in a very
special guest, one of our advisers, who's
also going to interact with our students.
But since this is all about students and
not about me, I'm going to hand over to
Pascal Gagneux, who's our associate
director, who runs the Specialization
Track in Anthropogeny. Pascal?
- [Pascal] Thank you very much, Ajit, and
welcome again to all of you for this great
afternoon. I am very happy to introduce
professor Francisco Ayala, who grew up in
Madrid, Spain. And during high school,
fired up by an especially enthusiastic
science teacher, developed a passion for
science. But then went on to study Physics
and Theology at the University of
Salamanca. Physics in Madrid and then
Theology at the Pontifical Academy in
Salamanca. And during his studies of
theology, he came across an interesting
book called, "Le Phénomène Humain, " that
was written by a Jesuit paleontologist,
Pierre de Chardin. And of course, "Le
Phénomène Humain" is "The Phenomenon of
Man, " and it is what CARTA is striving to
explain. What is it that makes us this
very strange ape, among other apes, but
with our very, very special attributes
that will be discussed today. Reading “Le
Phénomène Humain” sparked his interest in
Evolution and Genetics. And so, he
actually came to Columbia University, he
was very fortunate to have some advisors
in Spain that knew Theodosius Dobzhansky,
one of the major architects of the Modern
Synthesis of Evolution, who was a
geneticist interested in actually
observing and empirically measuring what
was going on in natural populations of
organisms that are busy evolving. And of
course, the work horse of naturally
evolving organisms was Drosophila. So long
before the advent of isozymes or
restriction enzymes or DNA sequence,
geneticist were very busy observing
generations after generations of these
tiny, little fruit-flies that annoy you,
around your bananas near your kitchen. And
selecting for new phenotypes and wondering
what it is. They could see the chromosomes
but they couldn't read the DNA yet. Once
there were restriction enzymes, they could
start cutting the DNA at specified places,
still not being able to read the actual
sequence. So, years of years of study, a
PhD on the genetics of Drosophila
continued, lead professor Ayala to look at
a variety of other organisms, and then
with the aid of more modern techniques.
Among these organisms, featured some very
prominent protozoans, like Trypanosomes,
in this case T.cruzi from South America
that causes Chagas disease that might be
one of the things that ail Darwin for so
long. It turns out, these organisms are
diploid, but they're mostly asexual. So,
here you have organisms with a lot of
variability that forgo sex for most of the
part. And it turns out, all these
organisms are parasitic. So, contributions
to the biology of these Trypanosomes
continued. So did contributions to this
major disease-causing organism, in this
case a merozoites of a Plasmodium
falciparum, the major disease of our
species. And by now, with help of
sequence...full on genome sequencing, it
was possible to actually retrace the
history of organisms, such as these
protozoa, that have been plaguing
human-kind for a very long time. And even
reconstruct the evolutionary history that
jumps between species. But, of course, the
fact that the book, one of the things that
sparked Francisco Ayala's interest in
evolution and genetics was The Human
Phenomenon makes him a card-carrying
anthropogenist, in terms of trying to
understand what it is that makes us such a
bizarre paradoxical ape. And I thought,
given today's topic, I would not end
before reading a short chapter out of
Dobzhansky's book called, "Mankind
Evolving, " from 1962, published a year
before I was born, and this is out of the
library of my late father, in which
Dobzhansky makes a very important thesis,
namely that "Human evolution has two
components: the biological, or organic;
and the cultural, or super-organic. These
components are neither mutually exclusive,
nor independent, but interrelated and
interdependent. Human evolution cannot be
understood as a purely biological process,
nor can it be adequately described as a
history of culture. It is the interaction
of biology and culture. There exists a
feedback between biological and cultural
processes." So, we'll have the pleasure to
hear professor Ayala talk about ethics and
morality today. And, of course, he is a
very well-know Evolutionary Biologist. He
has been called, rightly, the "Renaissance
Man of Evolutionary Biology, " and is a
recipient of many, many prestigious
honors, including the National Medal of
Science; he's a member of National Academy
of Science of the United States, of
Mexico, the Collège de France, Russia, and
Serbia and that's just a very small list
of the many declarations that he has been
given. So, without farther ado, let me
introduce Francisco Ayala on "Evolution of
Ethical Behavior and Moral Values:
Biology? Culture?"
- [Francisco] It is a pleasure to be here.
I have come from time to time to lecture
at UC San Diego. And, of course, I'm a
regular member of CARTA so I come for the
CARTA meetings again from time to time, as
often as I can. On occasion, I miss a
meeting because I have other obligations.
So, thank you very much for inviting me.
Thank you Ajit and Pascal and Ingrid.
Anyway, it is a pleasure to be here. This
is the Universal Tree of Life. It was duly
constructed 40 years ago with ribosomal
RNA genes which tells you the power of
molecular biology. That includes
everything that exists on Earth. You are
all familiar with bacteria. And of course
we tend to think of bacteria as organisms
that cause diseases, but bacteria are very
helpful to the rest of life, including
ourselves. We estimate that humans have
about one billion human cells. We have
about 10 billion bacterial cells because
bacterias are much smaller than eukaryotic
cells, which are what human cells are. So,
we have then this archaea that are very
microscopic organisms, very small like
bacteria who have been discovered as a
group just about the time, anywhere before
this tree was built. A couple of species
were known that were thought to be unusual
kinds of bacteria. But then you guys
discovered that actually there are very
numerous archaea. This tree is designed
with a convention that the length of each
branch is approximately, in a very rough
way, proportional to the diversity of the
organism in the branch. So you see the
branches of bacteria, we have almost as
many branches of archaea, and then of
course, we have the eukaryotes; the
plants, animals and fungi, as well as many
microscopic organisms, including some that
cause the severe diseases, as Pascal was
pointing out. And by the way, thank you
for the introduction. If we now look at
the animals, look with the small fraction
of the total organisms that exist on Earth
that the animals are. The animals are
organized in about 35 so-called "phyla, "
and within each phylum, there are some
classes. And here, we are going to look at
one, the mammals, is one of the classes.
And see here, we have a number of
branches. Coming here in this branch; to
rodents, to rabbits, and the primates. So
here is where we belong in one of these
branches. So, we are again a very, very
small fraction of the total animals. One
species among so very many, and the
animals are a small fraction of the total
of life. Now, if we look at the primates,
we find ourselves here at the end of this
branch, having separated from the branch
that goes to the chimps, which are, of
course, our closest relatives, closest
living relatives, about seven million
years ago. The chimpanzees are more
closely related to us than they are to the
gorillas, than we are to the gorillas.
Now, the question is, what happened since
our separation from the lineage, and of
course the chimpanzees. And here I have a
representation, again, about a few years
ago, of a member of a species in the
lineage that used to be called "Hominids,
" now they are called "Hominins." So,
starting about seven millions years ago,
we have a series of species, you know with
exotic names, Paranthropus or the
Pethicus. And we come in to
Australopithecus, and eventually Homo,
this Hominid man in Latin, and there's the
name of our species, as well as several of
our ancestral species. So, we, our
ancestral lineage, became bipedal shortly
after the separation from the lineage that
goes to the chimpanzees. So starting about
seven million years ago. So we have a
feature that distinguishes us clearly from
all the primates and the ape, particularly
more closely related primates, the apes
which is that bipedal gait. Then, we also
have, as another very distinct feature,
morphological feature: our large brain.
The bipedal gait probably started, at
least partially, already seven million
years ago, or so. But the brain does not
start to increase in size until about, the
time of Homo habilis, about two and a half
million years ago, or so. So, here we have
one of the Australopithecine species, the
so-called "Lucy, " Australopithecus
afarensis, living about four and half
million years ago, or so. And it is clear
that it is bipedal by just looking at the
hip bone. You can see the shape of it. If
we compare it with a hip of a human and
the one of the gorilla, maybe apparent in
a moment, and this apparently already here
that she had to have walked, as we do
walk, with a bipedal gait. By the way, I
have enlarged here relatively speaking the
size of the hip of Lucy, because Lucy, as
we will see, was much, much smaller than
we are. So here you have the way a gorilla
walks or a chimpanzee, resting on the
knuckles, this knuckle-walking it's
called. In relation to very long arms, you
need a very long hip as we saw in the
previous drawing. And here we have our
human hip. And here we have Lucy. Again,
she had to walk as we walk with a hip bone
the way she had it, she had to walk just
bipedally as we do. Now, the other feature
that I have pointed out as distinctive is
morphological feature, the large brain.
There is always a relationship between
different parts of the body with respect
to size. It's called "allometric
relationship." There is some kind of
equation that describe the change in size
of one part, the change in size of one
part relatively to other part as they vary
in size. So, what I am showing here with
this cartoon, is that the reason why we
have larger brain, which is as I said
started to grow at the time of Homo
habilis and may have been up to 600 cubic
centimeters or 300 grams. For much of the
previous history was about 300 to 400
cubic centimeters, the same size as the
brain of a chimpanzee or a gorilla. But
then, about two million and half years
ago, the brain started to grow. And what
I'm trying to show with this cartoon is
that it is not a question of allometric
growth. It's not only really because we
are bigger, we have bigger brain. Because
here we have another Australopithecine,
like robustus, that in terms of
volume-mass were as large as we are. And
yet their brain was still small. We have a
brain about 1,400 cubic centimeters, four
times the size of the brain of a gorilla
or chimpanzee, or more. And a little more
professionally ways or scientifically I
have shown in this slide that the growth
of the brain something that happened very
special in the evolution of Homo. So here
we have the body weight for various
animals, primates. And here the brain
size. So we look at the chimp and a
gorilla first, gorilla becomes three times
heavier than a chimpanzee, the brain also
increases somewhat. Australopithecus
afarensis, Lucy, and Orangutan and other
Australopithecines feed there. But look
what happens when we come to Homo habilis,
Homo erectus, or Homo sapiens. This triple
in size of the brain seems to happen, have
happened with relatively small increase in
body size. So it's not an allometric
growth. It's something else that was going
on. And what was going on, that's the
question. Here is a hypothesis of one of
the things and may have been not the only
one that explains why the brain becomes so
large. So we have bipedal gait for several
million years, what was happening with a
bipedal gait is we were thus...we were
changing very greatly were the arms and
the hands. Our arms are much more elastic
and much more moveable than those of the
chimpanzee or a gorilla. And particularly
the hand. Even a Chimpanzee cannot do
this, and although they seem to have five
fingers as we do, they cannot manipulate
objects the way we do. And they cannot
build objects the way we do. And they
don't have the sensitivity to the
temperature, roughness of surfaces and the
like. So, what is being proposed in this
slide, this hypothesis is that as a
consequence of the evolution of the arm
and the hand, our ancestors started to
build tools, not only use tools, but also
build tools. Now, building a tool requires
forming mental images of realities that
are not present. We build a knife because
we are going to use for cutting. We're
going to use it later. An arrow is built
for the purpose of hunting. Now, forming
mental images of realities that are not
present is a distinctively human attribute
and I will elaborate a little more later.
So, who were able to make the better
tools, those who were smarter, they were
more able to anticipate the future, the
realities that were not present, the
future use of the tools. So, the ones who
were smarter they made better tools. And
the tools help them to survive and
reproduce. So, this sort of feedback
cycle, then you have the brain becoming
larger and larger and tools being more and
more complicated as time goes by. There
are two other hypothesis that are I would
advance, to justify the increase in brain
size. But I don't want to deliver them
now. I would mention just one because it's
going to appear in a moment, is the
"cryptic ovulation" in human women. And
there are species, at least among the
primates, is the only one in which the
females have cryptic ovulation, that it is
not visible, not obvious. When, in most
primates, and most certainly apes, when
the female goes into estrus, the external
genitals enlarge. And very often acquire
varicose. So, the female is advertising,
"Now I'm fertile." So a male comes, mates
with that female. And from the
evolutionary point of view, there is no
reason for him to stay there because if
they had mated when she is fertile, the
probability that she would have been, had
become pregnant, that the mating would
have been successful is almost 100%. So
from the evolutionary point of view, it's
better for this male to look for another
female so that his genes can be
transmitted to as many progeny as
possible. Once ovulation become cryptic,
the male doesn't know when the female is
fertile. So the only way to make sure that
the fertilization has taken place is if he
stays there with the woman. So that gives
rise to the... It is the origin of the
nuclear family, and of course, the nuclear
family eventually gives, is the basis of
the evolution of societies. So I think the
cryptic ovulation and also social
organization that also accounts, in good
part, for the enlargement of the brain.
But I will not deliver that much more
except in passing again. Here, we have a
list of anatomical features that
distinguish us from the apes. "Bipedal
posture, " I have said enough about that.
"Opposing thumbs." I also pointed out that
this is an attribute that we have that is
really important for tool-making. "Large
brain, " of course. "Reduction of jaws and
remodeling of the face." That of course
happens because as the brain became
larger, for the child, baby to be able to
pass through the birth canal, some part of
the head had to be reduced. And that
happened to be the jaw. Of course, the
jaws of a chimpanzee or a gorilla
protrudes. Ours, they are much smaller. By
the way, also, a human baby is more a much
earlier stage, biologically speaking, than
the chimpanzee baby or a gorilla baby. So
then, we have here "cryptic ovulation"
which I already have spoken about. "Slow
development." And "modification of the
vocal tract and larynx, " so we can speak.
Chimpanzees cannot speak, not only because
they don't have the ability to have
language, but also they cannot emit the
sounds as we can. So now, a list here of
some of the behavioral differences between
us and the primates: "Intelligence."
First, abstract thinking. That is, we are
able to think about things that do not
exist in reality, you know, beauty for
example. We also have this attribute of
categorization. It is that we see
individual objects as members of the
general category. This is a very, very
powerful adaptation because, say you have
this fruit here, this is an apple, this
other one is a pear. When I see them and I
know to which category they belong, I know
a lot about their properties. It's a very
important feature of human intellect. And
then, reasoning and the power of logical
deduction which is very instinctively
human. Very briefly, of course we have
"Symbolic (creative) language." The
socialist who discovered symbolic language
also with this all and they communicate
symbolically. But this all determined by
their genes is not creative. We have
"Self-awareness and death-awareness." I
will say a couple of words about that. We
are aware that we exist as individuals.
And because we are aware that we exist as
individuals, we are death-aware. We are
aware that we will die because we see all
the members of our species, other humans,
they die. We are the only animal, I will
propose, although not everybody will agree
with me, that has self-awareness. And my
argument is that we know that we are the
only ones who have self-awareness. The
dog, or a horse or a bird do not know that
they exist as separate individuals because
if they would know that, they will have
death-awareness. I mean, they would have
that awareness, they will practice
ceremonial burial of the dead because you
know that you are going to die, you want
to be treated with respect when you die.
And that's what leads to the ceremonial
burial of the dead. [Inaudible 00:26:44]
at least for a few hundred thousand years.
But we are the only ones who practice
formal burial of the dead. Then you have
"tool-making and technology." I hardly
need to say anymore. "Science, literature,
art, ethics and religion, social
organization, legal codes." So now, I'm
going to discuss the issue of ethics
explicitly. Now, when philosophers talk
about ethics or morality, they distinguish
three kinds of issues. One which is called
"Metaethics, " which is "Why we ought to
do what we ought to do." Why is there are
ethical behavior? Then Normative ethics
which are the rules. "What we ought to
do." Maybe not to kill, not to steal. Then
Practical ethics, that is "Moral norms
applied to particular situations." Is it
acceptable to kill the baby in order to
save the life of the mother? Or the ones
not as transcendental as that. But we are
continuously dealing with practical ethics
in our lives. The Metaethical Doctrines.
Here, I have listed a few proper book
about, a philosophical book about, ethics
my list and also whom I list, two dozen of
them. But here, to have you an idea of
some of the kinds of doctrines that exist.
One, is "moral realism." The people who
believe that moral facts exist in the
world, that moral things are not that we
invent, but that they are existing in
reality. Killing is bad by itself. Then,
there is of course a "divine command, "
which is very important for people of
faith. The reason why killing is bad is
because God tells us that we should not
kill. And we have the Ten Commandments.
Then, "utilitarianism, " which is that
things are judged morally in terms of
their consequences with respect to other
individuals. The more individuals benefit
from a behavior, the more acceptable this
behavior is, morally. And then, this
"positivism, " which says there is no
rational foundations for morality, they
are useless issues arbitrarily made either
by individuals or by society. Also these
are the traditional and is still
occurring. Some of the Metaethical
Doctrines. And then we have Darwin. In
1859, he published "The Origin of
Species." At the very end of the book, he
has a short sentence. He says, "This idea
of life will be thrown up on the Origin of
Man." Out of the ideas that he presented
there. And indeed, that happened 12 years
later, when he published in 1871 "The
Descent of Man, " which were ethics is an
important consideration. So, what happens
is, once evolution came about, Theory of
Evolution, now there was a new way of
explaining morality. A result of
biological evolution. And we have two
schools, as it were. There are the people
who say we have morality, we have ethics
because of biological nature, because we
are human beings and thus determined in
our biology that we will see some actions
as being moral. And then there are the
people who say, "No, no. Morality is more
than a question of culture. It's not
biologically determined. It's a question
of cultural traditions, religious, or
otherwise." Now, usually, philosophers
argue that morality is mostly cultural.
Biologists, and evolutionists in
particular, argue that morality is mostly
biologically determined. What is happening
in these arguments is that they are
talking about two different things. We
have this two...these distinctions that I
am pointing out here. "The capacity for
ethics." That is why we judge some actions
as being moral and not always. This
capacity which is very different from the
Codes of Ethics, the "norms by which we
judge a particular action." This actually,
in terms of the classical ideas about
ethics, the capacity for ethics has much
more to do with metaethics. And then,
codes of ethics have much more to do with
normative ethics. If we distinguish these
two, the conclusion that I will grow is a
capacity for ethics is biologically
determined, but the norms of ethics, the
codes of ethics are the result of culture.
So, again, the argument between
philosophers and scientists, they're
talking about two different things, each
one of them is right about their own
things, their own ideas. So, to clarify
what I mean by this distinction alone,
imagine it's clear enough. Capacity for
ethics. We think about language is like
the capacity for symbolic verbal
communication. Then we have the Codes of
Ethics which relate more like to the
particular languages. It is clear that the
capacity for symbolic communication is
different from the language that we speak.
And we will say, this is biologically
determined, this is not. And there's the
argument that I need to make, the capacity
for ethics is biologically determined. The
Codes of Ethics are not. For there being
ethical behavior, we have to have a list.
We have to have these three abilities
joinly are necessary conditions for the
argument ethical behavior. The ability to
anticipate the consequences of one's
actions. Ability to make value judgments.
And the ability to choose between
alternative courses of action. We need the
ability to anticipate the consequences of
one's actions for there being morality.
Pulling the trigger, in a sense, is not a
moral action. Pulling the trigger is
immoral action, if I anticipate that by
pulling the trigger, I'm going to shoot
the bullet that is going to kill my enemy.
So in terms of the consequences of the
actions and because we are able to
anticipate the consequences of our
actions, that this is one of the
requirements for there being morality, as
I have pointed out as one of the
attributes related as distinctive feature
of the ability to anticipate realities
that are not present. And where does the
capacity come from? From our more advanced
intelligence. I already made the argument
that it is as a consequence of bipedal
gait that we eventually lead into
tool-making, which led to an enlarge brain
because people who are making tools are
being more successful than the ones who
are making, more able to make tools is
because they were smarter. So, you have
this feedback loop. Then we have the
ability to make value judgments. Value
judgments is when we consider one thing as
better than other. Value judgments exist
not only in morality, you know good versus
evil, of virtue versus sin. But we value
judgment with respect to many other
aspects of reality. You have economic
value judgments, artistic value judgments,
gastronomic, you know you prefer pears
rather than apples. So, we are making
value judgments all the time. And again,
that is related to our ability to form
categories, to see individual behaviors,
individual realities as member of general
classes. The second attribute that I was
listing among the attributes of human
intelligence in one earlier slide. And
then, the third, ability that we made to,
for there being morality is free will. If
I don't have the possibility of not
pulling the trigger, that pulling the
trigger will not be a moral action. The
digestion of food or the circulation of
the blood that's not a moral actions. We
cannot control it. Only, if I have control
over an action can I judge this action as
being either good or evil. I can then make
a value judgment. So, those are the
capacity for ethics. I have stated that it
is, we have capacity for ethics because we
have these three fundamental abilities.
Now, about the codes of ethics, norms by
which we judge a particular action. And
again, I'm going to remind you of the
distinction between these two
characteristics by comparing them with
language, where the distinction is very
obvious. So, the codes of ethics, they are
the result of cultural evolution. Now,
first we have in culture, what we call
culture, at least two dimensions. One is
individual actions, individual realities.
Like ideas, skills, habits, values,
beliefs. And then, we have culture as an
important set of components which are
social: inventions, technology, languages,
humanities, moral codes. So we have these
two sets of a characteristics. Cultural
evolution is made possible by a large
brain and is mediated by language. I think
those two things are very obvious. But we
will be delivering them a little more. So,
there is cultural evolution. It's not that
there is culture. As a culture evolves and
evolves following very similar to
biological evolution that the requirements
are the same. There has to be heredity,
they have to be transmitted from one
individual to another. There was to be
variation so there can be selection of one
way or another in the process of
evolution. And then there has to be
differential reproduction, natural
selection in biology, that these...some
traits, some behaviors may be transmitted
more effectively than others. Now, there
is heredity with respect to culture, but
it's a kind of heredity that's very
similar, very different from biological
heredity. Biological heredity has, what I
call here, vertical transmission. That is,
from parents to children. Cultural
heredity goes horizontal as well as
vertical. We can transmit our convictions,
our values, our ideas to people of our
generation, early generations, later
generations, whether they are related with
us or not. Again, biological evolution can
only be transmitted from parents to
children. We can transmit them to the
whole of the environment. There is another
very important difference which I am
setting it up here by calling biological
heredity, Mendelian, cultural heredity,
Lamarckian. Biological heredity is
Mendelian. Mendel is the first one who
discovered the existence of, what we now
we call genes and how they were
transmitted from parents to children. And,
biological heredity can only be
transmitted from parents to children.
Lamarck famously in the year in which
Darwin was born, had published in 1809 a
book in which he had presented
evolutionary ideas. He had very
distinctive ideas about heredity,
was...came to be called Lamarckian
heredity. That you don't only transmit the
genes that you have inherited from your
parents, when you have a recent mutation.
But you can transmit also the attributes
the that you acquire. When you go to the
gym and develop big muscles, your children
will be born with big muscles. Well, we
know that that's not true with respect to
biological heredity. But it is with
respect to cultural heredity. What we
transmit to other members of society of
our culture, are not only the ideas that
we got from our parents, but also ideas
and values that we may have gotten from
the whole human environment. So, in that
sense, what we learn through our life can
be transmitted, so it's Lamarckian
heredity. Many different characteristics
because these two of the fact that it is
Lamarckian. The acquired traits can be
transmitted and that it is transmitted
horizontal, meaning that culture is
transmitted much more efficiently without
comparison than biological heredity. Then,
there's variation. Remember for there to
be evolution, we have to have heredity, we
have to have variation, we have to have
differential reproduction. And it is clear
that there is variation with respect that
the ideas or values among individuals and
there's obviously variation among culture,
among tribes, nations. When we think about
a group as homogenous as a group that we
have here, we will surely find variation
with respect to certain moral values. I
mean, some people, some of you may be
definitely against abortion no matter
what, and others may say, "Well, to save
the life of the mother, maybe abortion is
morally acceptable." And so with other
things less significant. Obviously,
there's lots of variation among
individuals. And much more so among
groups, this will be very obvious now.
These days when we are experimenting the
tragedies along international boundaries,
battles have been happening all through
history. And I variation not only exists
between groups at any given time, but also
among groups. For example, look at the
behavior of the crusaders, the Crusades in
the 12th, 13th centuries. The way in which
people were behaving in the name of
Christianity, in the name of God, we will
find that terribly shocking and of course
it will be terribly unacceptable to us.
So, we have heredity. We have variation.
And of course, we have natural selection
because some variants are transmitted more
efficiently than others among individuals
or among groups. And I have a list of
things that are differentially transmitted
with ideas, skills, values, languages,
ethical codes, religious beliefs. As I was
walking here, I was walking with somebody
who was surprised that in the Basque
country where my parents come from, which
is a population that, about one million
and a half people in Spain and a little
less than a million in the French part. So
there are several provinces in each. That
there are seven very different dialects,
which one might consider a different
language. Well, if you go to New Guinea,
you find hundreds and hundreds of
different languages. Or you go to the
Maya, there are hundreds and hundreds of
different languages. Each small tribe has
a different language. So, there are lots
of variation. And of course there is
variation in ethical codes and in
religious beliefs. How do we have cultural
selection, differential reproduction?
Well, it is clear, again, that some ideas
are transmitted more effectively than
others. With respect to religion, I point
out here, this particular event in the
history of Christianity. As you know, the
early Christians, many of them have come
from Israel to Rome which was the Roman
Empire, which represented most of the West
at the time, they were being persecuted
until the year 325, when Emperor
Constantine becomes a Christian, becomes
converted and declares Christianity the
religion of the Roman Empire. So suddenly
most of the Western world, over night, so
to speak, becomes Christian. There's
cultural selection at an extreme. And of
course, there are also another way in
which cultural selection occurs which is
assimilation among tribes. It occurs among
the Maya, occurs in New Guinea among the
different tribes. Now, cultural evolution
has distinctive features with respect to
biological evolution which I list here
some of the most significant ones. First
of all it's more rapid, potentially can be
transmitted in a new invention, in a new
mutation a cultural mutation, can be
transmitted to all of mankind in one
generation. The iPhones that we were
turning off earlier. Sometimes my
undergraduate students take my iPhone, I
don't have it now because they asked me to
remove it so it won't ring while I'm
lecturing. So I tell them, "What kind of
iPhone do you think your parents were
using?" They all look at me surprised,
they start to look at each other and they
say, "They were not using iPhones." Well,
there's the point. Here, you have
something that, it's so many parts of
mankind, the majority of people have them.
But, anyway certainly in our world. And
yet, one generation ago, they didn't
exist. Nothing biologically, no matter how
beneficial, can be transmitted so
effectively. Very importantly, mutations
of these inventions and discoveries are
directed. Biological mutations, it depends
that they occur when they may occur
accidentally. And usually, they occur only
rarely and only very few of them are
beneficial. The majority are harmful
because we invent and discover things that
we think are beneficial to us. And
finally, there is group selection. Group
selection is when something benefits no
particular individual for the group to who
it belongs. Group selection, strictly
speaking, cannot take place in animals for
the following simple argument. Assume that
you have two groups. One has a mutation, a
change, this time I'm talking
biologically, that benefits all the
people, all the individuals in the group.
Normally, this altruistic behavior, the
person who wants to act in a way to
benefit others, that of course involves a
cost, at least a cost of carrying out
those actions. If you have that in a
population, the beneficial mutation is not
going to prosper because the person who is
behaving altruistically benefits all the
others, but at a cost to himself or
herself. So he will be selected against.
That's not so with humans because we
understand that we have something that is
beneficial for the group that we all are
going to benefit including I, myself as a
member of the group. So, groups that have
beneficial mutations, cultural mutations,
tend to be more prosperous than groups
that don't. So you have group is another
selection, another mode of selection that
exists with respect to culture. The final
stigmas that I want to weigh is... Very
importantly, for the last few millennia,
humans have adapted, more often, by
fitting the environments to their genes
than by fitting their genes to the
environments. What I mean by that, we came
from Africa, our ancestors came to, say
what is Europe or America for that matter,
probably no more than about 100,000 years
ago. Now, the colonizers of Europe, were
tropical animals adapted to the tropics to
an optimum temperature of about 25
Celsius. And yet, 100,000 years is not a
lot of time for biological evolution. It's
perhaps 4,000 generations or so for
humans. And yet, humans have colonized
Antarctica and Siberia and other parts
where the temperature is much colder. They
are able to, humans have been able to
colonize Siberia and, I don't mean
Antarctica, I mean actually the Arctic
region, Greenland and others. So humans
have been able to colonize Siberia or
Scandinavia not by changing their genes so
that they can live at colder climates,
colder temperatures, but rather by
clothing and housing. So, we are modifying
the environment according to the needs of
our genes. The people who live in Alaska
and in Siberia and in Scandinavia are as
adapted to a climate
temperature...tropical temperature as we
are. But they modified their environments
so as to adapt their environments to the
needs of their genes. You know, we travel
through rivers and oceans more
effectively, much more effectively than
any fish, not because we have gills or
fins, but because we use boats and we fly
much more effectively than any bird. We
don't have wings, but we build flying
machines. So, for the last few millennia,
and for the foreseeable future, human
evolution is going to be mostly cultural
precisely because it happens so much
faster. And of course, this is one of the
reasons why we may expect that morality
also will be...and ethical values will be
evolving over time. We can also already
see that happening. There are behaviors, I
will mention only one and I hope I don't
offend anybody. You know, when I was
growing up in Spain, we went to the
movies, the Hollywood movies, and there
everybody was smoking, including women
were smoking and then women in Spain
started to smoke. That was considered a
nice thing to do. Today, most of us
disapprove of smoking as a dreadful thing.
In fact, it makes me think that for the
last year, we have had over 300 people
killed in these mass atrocities. That's
only one per day. About 10,000 per day die
from smoking. So, no wonder many of us
consider smoking not acceptable, morally.
I'm using this, by way of example. I think
it's very obvious the moral values are
evolving and will continue to evolve. So,
again, the conclusions that I have been
drawing, I have been elaborating is that
capacity for ethics is a result of
biological evolution. The codes of ethics
are the result of cultural evolution. And
very briefly, as I said that I was going
to do, two quotations from Darwin, because
the way I read Darwin, he was not always
fully consistent and not necessarily
elaborated his points as much as he could
have. But his position was very much one
that I have been advancing here. Here you
have this quotation from The Descent of
Man: "An animal that will eventually
advance socially in its instincts could
inevitably acquire moral sense or
conscience, as soon as its intellectual
powers had become as well, or nearly as
well developed, as in man." He's saying,
you have intelligence, the kind as we do,
advanced intelligence, you will have
morality. So, this is biologically
determined. But, he's saying that that
doesn't mean there'll be the same moral
values as we do. This animal who will
become very intelligent will have
morality, but the values will be,
probably, different. So again, values,
determined by culture. This is the book
where I elaborate these ideas, published
in 2007 and I'm proud to tell that
tomorrow I plan to mail to the publisher,
Oxford University Press, the second
edition of this book. Thank you very much.
- Thank you very much, Francisco. We have
time for some questions.
- [Man 1] I'm sorry. Some people talk
about an arc of moral progress and the
implication is that ethics revolving,
there are things today that we look back
on with shame and horror. Like it took
thousands of years before people figured
out that slavery was a bad thing. And for
a long time, nobody thought it was a bad
thing. And now everybody thinks it's a bad
thing. And there are people in this
audience that, they dissect animals and
crush their spinal cords and I think in 50
years we're going to look back and say,
"That's a bad thing." Do you believe that
there is an arc of moral progress that
evolution is driving us towards a
consensus about what's right and what's
wrong? Or is it just going to be
universally variable, depending on your
culture?
- I think, since I'm an optimist, that
there is progress, evolutionary progress
that is going to wake with respect to
culture. With respect to biology,
biological evolution is so slow. That's
not something that we will see in our
lifetime and the lifetime of our
grandchildren or the grandchildren of our
grandchildren, over thousands of years.
You know, after all, evolving on different
climates for the last, at least 100,000
years. And yet, we have virtually not
changed. We have changed in some features,
color of the skin, configuration of the
body, which are very directly responding
to the resonance of light and to other
features of the environment. But,
culturally, yes, we are going to continue
evolving, with less progress or not is
going to depend on your point of view. I
think that by and large, when we progress,
that I was saying and I will reiterate
now, I think we are becoming morally more
subtle, if you wish, more sophisticated,
more demanding.
- [David] Francisco, David Bren. Thank
you. Excellent talk. I was wondering,
though, if you think that, the thing that
causes so many species to overshoot in
some trait or another trait and you showed
Descent of Man, Darwin said was sexual
selection. And often it's visible in an
exaggerated physical trait. And I was
wondering if you think that sexual
selection may have been responsible for
some of the overshoot, intellectual
capacity overshoot, in humanity. And I'd
like to site one physical exaggeration
that's almost never mentioned, and have
you comment on it. And that is the fact
that usually it's the male that shows some
exaggerated trait, and therefore we
suspect sexual selection. But in humans,
blatantly, the gender that has been
sexually selected for physical attributes
that make it more different than apes,
that make that gender seem more different
than the basic ape plan is clearly the
females. They are less ape-like than we
are, than we males. And I don't think that
I'm going to be hit by any of the women
here for saying that.
- No, they are certainly smarter than we
are.
- But it suggests that we've been
subjected to sexual evolution.
- Well, there's no question that there is
sexual selection, as you have pointed out,
in humans. And there are people who think
that sexual selection may have played a
major role in evolution of ethics. I do
not see it that way. I see the evolution
of morality in a different way, both with
respect to the capacity, as well as with
respect to the norms because they
contribute. There is sexual selection, but
I don't see it as a driving force in the
case of morality. But some people disagree
with me.
.♪ [music] ♪